every major studio has these projects
that they were extremely excited about
once
only to drop them before they ever hit
the big screen and universal pictures is
no different
from ambitious sequels to forgotten
comic book movies to a whole cancelled
universe
these are the universal movies we'll
never get to see
everyone can agree that cowboys are
awesome as are ninjas
as well as vikings well some geniuses
thought
what if they were all combined into one
wonderful megatro
that's the rough idea behind the graphic
novel cowboy ninja viking
by aj lieberman and riley rosmo the
story is about a psychotherapist who can
transform into multiple
secret agent personas that take the form
of a cowboy
a ninja and a viking chris pratt had
signed on to star as the good doctor
and game of thrones and breaking band
director michelle mclaren
would have made her feature film debut
working from a 65 million dollar budget
with a script that had been written at
various stages by
guys who'd worked on rampage the
hangover 2 and deadpool
the film had a projected release date of
june 28 2019
and it looked to be a fun action comedy
and a likely blockbuster
but just as casting was ramping up
universal pulled the movie off its
schedule
and called off production delaying the
film indefinitely
according to an insider the film had
some screenplay issues
and rumors of calling the whole thing
off bounced around for five
months before universal threw in the
towel according to a report by wired in
2017
halo publisher microsoft aggressively
tried to get a film version of its mega
popular video game series going in 2005.
the software giant took bids from
interested studios
and ultimately the only two parties left
vying for the right to make halo were
fox and universal
who decided to team up and split the
likely enormous production costs of
making a sci-fi combat film
at first things were going just fine
halo got a screenplay by 28 days later
writer alex garland
and district 9 creator neil blomkamp
signed on to direct
and that's when the clashes with the
studio began he thought he could make a
cool
cyberpunk type movie while he said
executives wanted a quote
generic boring film with the parties so
deeply at odds
halo fell apart fans still have a slim
read of hope to hold on to however
showtime announced the live action halo
series in 2020
and if that does well enough who knows
perhaps a movie might be in the cards
after all after the release of the
unnecessary but
successful jaws 2 in 1978 and the
success of the full-length disaster
movie parody airplane in 1980
john's producers david brown and richard
zaneck wondered if the same
rapid-fire joke format could be applied
to the jaws franchise
they contacted maddie simmons publisher
of iconic
70s humor magazine national lampoon and
the man behind the brand that released
animal house
simmons decided to be a producer too and
the three guys
set out to make jaws 3. or as they
hilariously called it
jaws 3 people zero the producers pursued
joe dante to direct as he just helmed
the jaw's knock-off called piranha
and they got regular lampoon
contributors todd carroll and john
hughes to write a very silly script
ultimately xanax and brown were afraid
to go into the water
as they didn't think it would be the
best idea to so thoroughly mock their
meal ticket
in the end universal did make a third
jaws movie 1983's non-humorous and
famously bad
jaws 3d hubet guillermo del toro
a modern visionary of the spooky and
surreal could adapt a classic work of
terrifying science fiction by the
legendary h.p
lovecraft at the mountains of madness is
a 1931 novella about scientists who
discover the ancient and frightening
alien mutants who live within antarctica
and making it into a movie has long been
a passion project for del toro
because of his proven track record along
with interest from tom cruise and james
cameron
universal similarly thought that at the
mountains of madness just might make a
great movie
and the studio paid for del toro to come
up with some creature designs
what the studio didn't like was del
toro's projected budget of 150 million
dollars on a project that would most
definitely earn an
r rating for its violence and general
scariness
thus limiting its box office draw by
shutting out teenage film-goers
del toro ultimately blamed himself
saying that he quote
should have lied to universal and just
told him that he'd shoot for a pg-13
ending
so as to get them to green light the
movie it remains a tantalizing missed
opportunity
and del toro has vowed that he's not
giving up on trying to get it made
former bodybuilder and california
governor arnold schwarzenegger first
proved that he could headline a movie
with the release of the epic 1982
fantasy
conan the barbarian in the film
schwarzenegger takes the classic heroes
journey as a mighty
muscle-bound sword-carrying warrior out
to avenge the death of his parents
crush your enemies see them driven
before you
and they hear the lamentation of your
women the film was a surprise hit
earning 39 million dollars at the
domestic box office
indicating a big appetite for a sequel
conan the destroyer followed in 1984
and brought in similar revenues for
universal a third movie in the series
finally got underway
about 30 years later chris morgan
screenwriter of multiple fast and
furious films
came on board with a solid premise for a
film about an
older conan and schwarzenegger was
excited by the project
however universal had a number of
concerns that morgan and others working
on the project
couldn't overcome the project remains in
limbo but in 2019
screenwriter chris morgan told the
hollywood reporter that he still had
hopes of bringing the old man conan
movie
provisionally titled the legend of conan
to theater someday
before marvel and disney assembled to
launch the marvel cinematic universe
the comics publisher contracted with
various studios to bring its superheroes
to the big screen
universal landed the rights to the
incredible hulk and with hulk in
production in late 2002
the studio was so confident that it made
agreements to make two more marvel
movies
the comic giants movie division
announced that year that universal will
be tackling one of their oldest
characters
namor the submariner and one of their
newest prime
the task of bringing the epic story of
submariner an amphibious king from
atlantis to the screen
fell to dave itself best known for
scripting the film
road to perdition meanwhile the duo of
chris conroy
and don collimay got the prime gig which
concerned a teenaged boy who could turn
into a full-grown superhero
seeing as it's been roughly 20 years
since these films were announced
during which time marvel found itself a
home at disney
submariner is likely dead in the water
and it's no longer prime's time
of course that doesn't mean they've been
entirely forgotten there's still a
chance that submariner in particular
could show up in the marvel cinematic
universe sometime very soon
who framed roger rabbit ushered in a new
era of projects that mixed live action
with animation
and helped to bring on the music video
for paula abdul's
opposites attract the song is a duet and
the male voice is credited to the wild
pair
a singing duo consisting of bruce
deshazer
and marv gunn but in the video those
vocals are synced up to the flapping
mouth of an animated cat named
mc skatcat the clip proved so popular
that virgin records gave
mc scat cat and his expanded universe of
cool feline friends
including fats taboo maestro leo
kathleen and silk a spinoff album in
1991
called mc scat cat and the stray mob
while the video for the single
scat strut performed well on mtv it
stalled at number 96 on the billboard
hot 100.
that lack of public interest is likely
what killed development of more
mcstatcat related multimedia projects
see at the peak of this minor mania
virgin music and universal pictures
discussed a big screen
mc scat cat movie that would have
blended live action and animation
it never got past the planning stages
and neither did a proposed mc
scat cat saturday morning cartoon for
fox
after disney launched the marvel
cinematic universe and warner brothers
created the dc
extended universe universal realized it
could have its own interconnected film
series too
remembering that it made classic monster
movies in the 1930s
including dracula frankenstein the
invisible man
and pride of frankenstein among other
classics universal decided to reboot and
link those films together
in 2014 universal announced that
filmmakers alex kurtzman and chris
morgan would lead the project
which the studio ultimately named the
dark universe in 2017.
along with that news universal said it
would produce bride of frankenstein
directed by bill condon
and scheduled for release on february 19
2019
that would be followed by movies with
javier bardem as frankenstein's monster
johnny depp is the invisible man and
russell crowe is dr jekyll and mr hyde
but death is a doorway and the past
cannot remain buried forever
and none of these movies happened why
well blame the mummy this early dark
universe
entry earned savage reviews and a so so
money losing 80 million dollars at the
domestic box office
a few months later kurtzman and morgan
left the dark universe
and the studio postponed bride of
frankenstein from its 2019 release
saying in a statement that the film
needed quote more time to develop
nevertheless in january 2019 universal
proclaimed that the dark universe was
over
but said that it would continue to
develop some of those monster movies
into standalone films
in early 2020 we saw the first fruits of
those labors
when the invisible man starring
elizabeth moss arrived in theaters to
positive reviews and a strong box office
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you